alright hello everyone and welcome to
the infectious disease virtual event my
name is Matt Flegal and I am a research
scientist so today I'm going to be
presenting on invivo models for
infectious disease research through the
years basically to give you an overview
of how things have progressed if you
will over the last quarter century or so
do feel free if you have any questions
please submit them I will follow up with
you via email so feel free whatever you
wish so to kind of set the stage within
an infectious disease research and vivo
animal models truly are vital this is a
very complex discipline there are a lot
of pieces that have to fit together and
working in in lab animals is one of the
principal ways that were able to more
precisely model the environment that our
therapeutics or even for basic research
are going to be applied within we can
use an actual immune response
we can also attenuate that immune
response to answer other questions we
can test and better explore the
transmission the pathology of the
various infectious organisms and
obviously if we're going to be testing
therapeutics if we're going to be
testing vaccines animal models are
critical because at the end of the day
the interactions between these pathogens
and the host are very complex and quite
honestly we get if you will surprised
more often than not and the way that we
can better put these things together
before we move into human clinical
trials is again using these lab animals
oh because at the end of the day
for much of what we do humans simply
aren't appropriate for the research and
testing if pathogens are serious or even
fatal or untreatable or the conditions
creates temporary or even permanent
damage it's just not appropriate to test
them in humans
that's the lab animals but these need to
be justified so that's if you will the
other side of the coin whenever possible
we want to use in vitro we want to use
ex vivo experiments those should be our
first choice for a variety of reasons
one animal welfare we have an ethical
obligation to our lab animals to treat
them properly to see their welfare to
minimize their discomfort along the way
but there are other reasons as well
they're expensive they're very time
consuming there's individual variability
not just in between species but also
between the individuals within a species
and on the one hand that's wonderful
because it's the same in humans so it
better reflects the environment that our
therapeutics are going to go into but on
the other hand it leads to a call it a
reduction in predict predictability
along the way hence the unexpected
interactions the results and also is
there a good animal model is there an
appropriate species for what we're
trying are we sure and then finally in
something I'm going to talk about a fair
amount is it requires a surprisingly
high level of technical skill and that's
an important concept to have and it's
one of the things that tends to get
missed when looking at the use of these
in vivo models yes there are standard
techniques they are relatively well
established they are relatively
consistent in the gross details across
the industry but within that there is
the possibility for error and
it has nothing to do with things I
talked about earlier as far as the
species and the animal individuals but
in how you perform these techniques and
whether you're applying them properly
and part of this if you go through the
literature there are very few good
references that have a program detail in
appropriate detail can go into a fair
amount of depth and we'll talk about
that a little bit as well but those
papers or those presentations that will
give you those fine details that may
reduce the variability or give you a
better tighter data set there aren't a
lot out there hands-on training there's
not a lot of good outside hands-on
training events so there are a few
places that specialize in them but not
many and often they are both cost
prohibitive but also they're simply not
available in your individual area so
again yes there are untold numbers of
articles that have at least as a
component within them some sort of in
vivo experiment but they tend to
minimize the descriptions of the actual
technical conduct how did you do the
things that you did within this study
they often don't report errors so the
model development the trials and the
difficulties and the learning curves
that you went through are often not
reflected in it which means that when
you are trying to mimic this paper with
this publication that you are pulling
from there's a lot that's left out those
are the details and those are the
details that can lead you down if you
will the wrong path and one of the
things that is wonderful in this era of
the Internet and I'm old enough to
remember when we didn't have one is
surprisingly the details of the tech
conduct in a paver aren't actually 100%
accurate when you talk to the people who
are actually doing the work you may find
out that there are differences so you
were trying to mimic a publication that
at least in the areas that you are
focused on may be inaccurate and there's
another thing just as there is if you
will the welfare of the lab animals that
we have to be cognizant of the people
working with those lab animals have to
have a high degree of empathy you have
to want to take proper care of these
animals to be successful in this field
but the downside of that is you tend to
lose technical skill because there is a
high turnover rate there is a high
burnout rate it is hard emotional work
and finally there aren't many good
university programs out there that give
you good hands-on training in how to do
these kinds of studies so our new
scientists that come out aren't enormous
ly well prepared the actual day to day
technical challenges that they're going
to face I'll give you an example before
we move on so oral dosing it's probably
the most common form of dosing in lab
animal medicine
it appears relatively simple we're going
to administer this in to the esophagus
so that it goes to the stomach or better
yet I'll talk about that in a second
getting directly to the stomach
it's translatable most of the
medications that we're going to give
down the line to humans are going to be
orally administered so there's a huge
positive in administering them that way
in our lab animal subjects as well
because it's an apples-to-apples
comparison so we like that it's
translatable um and yes it requires a
fair amount of practice and work to get
a base
competency in this the problem is basic
competency isn't enough there are so
many opportunities in this one of the
most simple and straightforward of
techniques to create hidden errors and
the real problem is it will affect your
data and you will never know that your
data has been compromised
all you know is what is on your excel
sheet or in your graphs or what have you
at the end but you don't know that that
data has been compromised by how you
acquired it and also in many cases
because there is a high level of
technical skill needed because there is
an expense and it's not just the expense
of the lab animals that we're gonna work
on there's the facilities around them
and the people to care for them and all
the rest of these components so what
ends up happening is you try and do as
few studies as possible you want the
biggest bang for the buck with them
which is great except it means that
you're not going to have lots of studies
you may be making go no-go decisions on
these studies or on these compounds with
one or two studies and if you do them
poorly you're going to make the wrong
decision oh so I alluded earlier do you
give it into the esophagus do you get it
to the stomach are you doing it properly
to do so because if you give a test
material to the esophagus then did all
of it make it to the stomach with some
of it expelled with some of it sprayed
out on the cage floor possibly um so
maybe you didn't give the full dose that
you thought you had um and never mind
that again it's a great technique
because it's translatable and we like
that but is it the right route different
lab animals have different ph's in their
stomach if you have a test material that
can not tolerate a three point eight or
four point
four or 1.9 pH by the time it gets to
the GI tract to be absorbed the
compounds already been degraded and then
do you have the right equipment for
these species and strength and I use
this to illustrate this is one simple
quote/unquote straightforward technique
but so much complexity in so much
thought needs to go in the selection and
then the application of this technique
so now I'm going to talk about what I
have seen over the last 25 years and I'm
going to do it to illustrate how far
we've come but also if you will some of
the pieces that maybe we have lost along
the way that we probably would have been
better off not losing them so this is a
picture of me 1993 on and you may notice
I got involved in surgery fairly early
in my career so a lot of my examples as
I kind of go further in this
presentation they're going to have that
so just bear with me so when I started
in the field yes there are regulations
yes you must follow them on the guide
for the care and use of laboratory
animals is kind of the Bible if you will
within at least the United States
there's PHS policy that's very similar
but the guide is pretty much our
standard speaking just about surgery 25
years ago there was half a page that
talked about the regulations covering
anesthesia and analgesia and just to
clarify for those of you um for instance
who are in Iacocca or QA regulations is
a little bit of a misnomer um the guy
applies in specific situations but it
has become if you will the voluntary
document that we follow as part of the
true regulation which is the Animal
Welfare Act and so with that said
surgery and post surgical care
less than a page four paragraphs of
seven paragraphs total giving you your
guidance for working on surgery which I
would hopefully would all agree is a
pretty serious all component and could
have impacts on animal welfare
twenty-five years later we've gone from
less than a page to nine pages and it's
been expanded greatly it talks about the
training it talks about the specifics of
how to perform operating technique how
the functions of the team work it's much
more comprehensive than it was the
training so 25 years ago it was for all
intents and purposes apprentice style
training you with minimal to no skills
were hired into a university or a
company or what have you and someone who
had more experience than you showed you
how to do things your co-workers were
your primary source of any information
and this led to if you will a telephone
tag style of information and as anyone
who's played that party game knows what
you hear five people into that game is
not what was originally set and that
happened a lot and there was also a
piece of this where you were being
trained by someone who hopefully
remember as much as possible about the
person who was being trained who had
trained them who had trained them and
oftentimes you could go back to someone
who was basically inventing it on their
own another thing when it started and
this was both good and bad a vast
majority of the people who perform in
these techniques on a day to day
situation were either veterinary
technicians or people with high school
graduates oh sorry with high school
diplomas
most of the time if you had a more
advanced degree you were overseeing the
studies or you were designing the
studies but you weren't working on the
studies maybe you did that in school as
part of your degree but you got out of
that when you started and so that meant
that the scientific judgment on a study
tended to be in that scientists hands
who was overseeing the project the study
director if you will um conferences
there weren't many that focused on
actual technical skills again they might
spend 30 seconds talking about we did
these technical things but then we went
on to what everyone was at the
conference for which was here's the data
here's the graphs again this is a long
time ago so these were 35 millimeter
slides in a carousel and really at the
time a lass was the group that put this
together and that's changed that's
changed a lot um not so much in the
training it's still very heavily a
hands-on apprentice style of training
but now the average person who comes
into the field has a bachelor's often in
biology or chemistry or lab animal
medicine um but there are a lot of
outside training organizations um not
the least of which is the one hosting
this very seminar and that's important
because if you think about it
25 years ago if you wanted to see a
presentation your company was going to
pay one two three thousand dollars and
take you out of work for one two three
four five days and send you to it now
there are webinars there are events like
this there are online videos there's so
much more information out there oh there
are textbooks that we simply didn't have
back in the day um there are textbooks
on surgery on anesthesia on technical
skills um back in the day we had Pollak
mills in Wayne sports surgery and
technique in the
rat and that's it now
we have online forms you can go and
interact with thousands or tens of
thousands of people in lab animal
community and ask them questions and
many of them will help you this is
amazing so one of the things that that
has led to is there's much more of a
sense of if you will professionalism
there are industry-wide standards we
have metrics and we believe in metrics
the conference's started to focus more
on this technical refinement um again
even things like PubMed knew twenty-five
years ago I spent a lot of time in
University Libraries chasing down
physical papers and then taking the
plastic credit card that I had from that
library going to the photocopier
photocopying whatever articles now if I
need an article I don't want to PubMed I
can go into other search engines and I
can just pull it and read it I used to
spend as so many of us did you could
spend an entire afternoon in a library
if you get three or four papers now I
can pull up almost every paper it can be
in a foreign language and I can
translate it that's huge it gives us so
much more information than we ever had
so what about technology well let's just
talk about a mention um they were just
getting into the field and they were
enormously expensive and rare and
usually they were in human hospitals
because you did not have them in a lab
animal situation so the number of times
that we would do MRI on a rabbit for
instance where at one o'clock in the
morning because that was the only time
it wasn't in use we would take it to the
University Hospital and get our scans
done and then disinfect the entire area
so that patients could come in at 6
o'clock that same morn um because it was
rare and because it was expensive we
didn't use it very
um for drug delivery we had infusion
technologies and those were often human
equipment human catheters um the
technology was honestly pretty crude
wonderful if you like rebuilding things
on the fly in an emergency but not very
good for out-of-the-box
um even or caging it was unwieldy it
wasn't designed for our type of use it
lacked ergonomics they were wonderful
fortunately they did a wonderful job
protecting our lab animals they often
didn't do such a great job protecting us
working with them but let's take imaging
for example um now it's expensive but
it's mature ok because most of our lab
animal species are small you know you're
putting it into a six or seven pound
rabbit where you're putting it into a
250 gram rat the equipment that we had
25 years ago was designed at the
smallest for pediatric patients so a 40
50 pound human child
now there's equipment that's actually
designed for the size and weight ranges
that we work in and it's accepted by the
scientific community you have to do a
lot of if you will selling back in the
day to bring these through now it's
accepted and it's understood and there's
information and every time you do a
study with them you're not a pioneer um
and they're new high resolution
ultrasounds their new MRI technologies
on so on and I'll set a stage a little
bit for a brief video but this video is
just to give you an idea
this isn't 25 years ago this is 15 years
ago and they were some of the first
ultrasound scans that I did where things
really started to come together where
when you can image a the fetal heart of
a rat in utero or you can find
complications and genetic abnormalities
in larger species that we just never
were able to do before I really think
that this imaging really came into its
own in the early 2000s
you
all right and again infusion for drug
delivery and our skill to do it has
kicked in all that up in the upper right
hand corner is a mouse femoral artery so
the black suture that you see up at the
top is a little bit smaller than the
diameter of human hair so we've learned
a lot along the way and again our
practices and her methodology are now
standardized and there are people who
make much better specialized equipment
you know the access technologies and the
SI eye and the instep and so on they've
brought real refinement to the
technologies that we have even caging
there's great of choice the ergonomics
are better for us as well as the lab
animals on enrichment is better so that
we can improve the quality of the
animals experience and now they're
really designed for us to work with them
and they're not just simply housing and
then other thing we understand and more
importantly it is generally accepted so
many of these basic concepts now and
that's a huge improvement so we
understand things like the
appropriateness of true asepsis and
analgesia not just for the animals
welfare although frankly I think that
may be the most important but also
because we don't want all of the
cascading effects on our study data we
understand that animals dard pain and
distress so much better there's so much
more study so now we can pick up on
subtle signs where we just didn't have
that information before and these have
been in partnership with human pediatric
nurses and the Nick Hughes and what have
you who also have patients who can't
speak and articulate and we've learned
from them and in some cases they've
learned from us and those technical
skills as I said at the very beginning
have becomes
standardized across the field we
understand things like fair housing for
primates and better enrichment and the
effects of ambient noise and how to
provide a better environment around our
lab animals the things that have changed
so I'm being a little facetious here but
ergonomics and safety um in 94 we didn't
think about you know yes we wore basic
PPE um we tried not to get injured um
but we didn't do a great job on and in
real terms that's why you don't see a
lot of people from when I started still
doing hands-on lab animal because our
economics were never a focus and we
injured ourselves wrists shoulders backs
eyes
necks we put ourselves in awkward
positions and it didn't do us a whole
heck of a lot of good so now in part
because as our level of work has
increased the cost of training someone
to be able to do it has gone up so you
really want to protect them a lot more
staff retention has become more valuable
you know when I started and I was
working with non-human primates in the
middle picture we were wearing those and
gloves and we were working with
conscious primates and if you were to
win if you will the reverse lottery
where the primate that [ __ ] you
happened to have herpes B you could die
you could be on a cycle of air or some
other on a suppressant for the rest of
your life you know we thought it was
amazing when we started getting Kevlar
sleeves over in the left um now you
wouldn't dream of working with them like
that and not just the safety of the
people working with them but the safety
of the primates it's better we have
better materials we know
handle them so that they're better
protected while we're working that has
been a tremendous change 11 I kind of
like this particular meme if you will so
a lot has gotten better but we have
become I think more hyper focused and
our studies are more streamlined and
that can be all to the good
but as our studies have become more
expensive and complicated we've reduced
the number of animals on study the
studies themselves are harder to conduct
so we're less prone and less willing to
run them the skill level is higher and
the actual skill that we need to have
high quality data is even higher than
that and there's an attractiveness of
expensive technology but that adds to
the cost which again goes on to reduce
if you will the instances of doing these
and also we focus because there's so
many more publications we tend to accept
the publications on critically and just
follow them so I'll leave you with just
a few things to think about that I think
have lost their emphasis over the last
quarter century and they deserve a
comeback and one is gather as much data
as you can something as simple as when
your animal is humanely euthanized at
the end of the study look at everything
if you don't look you're not going to
see things and I can tell you as so many
of my colleagues can as well that after
1 to 3 decades of this you get surprised
you get surprised a lot that surprise is
information that you would not have had
otherwise but if you're not looking if
you were trying to reduce the footprint
of your studies then you're losing data
and it's a terrible thing to find out
about that missing piece of data when
for instance you were
hound fails in clinical trials because
you would have seen it but you weren't
looking um don't discount human
interaction that the internet is
wonderful again I remember when I got on
the internet at work for the very first
time and trust me there was far less on
it back then but don't focus on looking
at things electronically talk to people
the wonderful thing about technology now
is we can use that technology to then
reach out to the people who generated it
you can email the authors of papers you
can call them many of them will talk to
you
who doesn't like talking about their
work and what they do and then you can
get the real information but it has
become so easy to take a three sentence
reply on a listserv or read seventeen
papers talk to the people who did the
work and learn what they know and be
often surprised by how much wasn't in
the information that you had and then
another piece that I would like to point
out I've been training surgeons for
about twenty years now and I will tell
you that some of the best surgeons I
have ever trained some of the best lab
animal technicians I have ever trained
at high school diplomas came from other
careers but they were smart and they
were capable and the amazing thing as
I've told so many of my direct reports
over the years is we can read the exact
same books that everyone else can you
can educate yourself at work and I would
put out that when you're surrounded by
truly smarter scientists you can learn a
lot from them possibly faster so don't
discount these people don't kind of put
aside these people who have all the
skills and all the drive and all the
determination and all the intelligence
just
because they don't fit a certain
criteria and that I think is maybe where
we have lost the most in this field over
the last 25 years and my hope is that we
can get back to looking at the quality
of the people and bringing those
exceptional people in and with that I'm
going to say thank you again if you have
any questions please feel free to email
them in and I will be more than happy to
answer them but with that thank you so
much